Tasha: 哇好粉那今天
Tasha: Wow, so pink today.
Katrina:  找一双粉袜子
Katrina: Find a pair of pink socks.
Tasha: 嘟嘟 嘟嘟嘟
Tasha: Doot doot doot doot.
Tasha: 我们来玩个游戏吧
Tasha: Let's play a game.
Jake: 玩什么呀
Jake: What game?
Tasha: 哼你这样子
Tasha: Hmph, like this.
Jake:这样然后呢
Jake: Like this, then what?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 这个脚也抵住这里
Tasha: Put your foot here too.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then?
Tasha: 你玩过吗
Tasha: Have you played this before?
Jake:我可能玩过
Jake: Maybe I have.
Tasha: 嘿嘿然后石头剪刀布
Tasha: Hehe, then rock-paper-scissors.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 然后呢哎
Tasha: And then, hey.
Tasha: 不对是你往后一格
Tasha: No, you move back one step.
Jake:往后一格
Jake: Move back one step.
Tasha: 喔喔呵呵
Tasha: Oh oh, haha.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 什么这是簪子
Tasha: What, this is a hairpin.
Jake:你的
Jake: Yours?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 簪不上
Tasha: Can't pin it.
Tasha: 太过分了
Tasha: That's too much.
Tasha: 下播了不玩了
Tasha: I'm logging off, not playing anymore.
Shure: 早上好
Shure: Good morning.
Tasha: 好香啊
Tasha: Smells so good.
Tasha: 这是在煎什么
Tasha: What are you frying?
Shure:  煎面包
Shure: Bread.
Shure:  哎我刚才拿出来面包呢
Shure: Hey, where did I put the bread just now?
Katrina:  这些东西都放哪了呀
Katrina: Where did you put all these things?
Tasha: 这呢啊
Tasha: Here, huh.
Shure:  随便放里面
Shure: Just put them inside randomly.
Tasha: 他拿什么
Tasha: What did he take?
Alice: 看到了
Alice: I saw it.
Alice: 你这衣服是要洗的吗
Alice: Are these clothes for washing?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Alice: 你没开啊
Alice: You haven't started it.
Shure:  对对我等一会弄完了
Shure: Right, right, I'll do it in a bit.
Alice:我给你开了吧
Alice: I'll start it for you.
Shure:  啊行
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure:  你帮我倒点洗衣液然后开了就行
Shure: Just pour some laundry detergent for me and start it.
Shure:  这面包忒油了
Shure: This bread is too oily.
Shure:  哇好多蚂蚁啊
Shure: Wow, so many ants!
Katrina:  我去
Katrina: Oh my!
Katrina:  那个饭还能吃吗
Katrina: Is that food still edible?
Alice: 能吧
Alice: Probably.
Alice: 吃鸡蛋吗
Alice: Want some eggs?
Alice: 微微
Alice: Tasha.
Tasha: 生鸡蛋哦哦
Tasha: Raw eggs, oh!
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 这是干嘛
Alice: What's this for?
Tasha: 消消肿
Tasha: To reduce swelling.
Shure:  早起一杯黑咖啡
Shure: A cup of black coffee in the morning.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Katrina:  谁闹钟响了
Katrina: Whose alarm is ringing?
Tasha: 不是我
Tasha: Not mine.
Tasha: 嗯怎么不响
Tasha: Hmm, why isn't it ringing?
Tasha: 煎鸡蛋嗯
Tasha: Fried eggs, hmm.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Tasha: 好苦涩
Tasha: So bitter.
Shure:  面包片对
Shure: Toasted bread, right.
Shure:  煎的面包片
Shure: Toasted bread slices.
Shure:  杨老板呢
Shure: Where's Jake?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶应该可以吧
Tasha: Fresh milk should be okay, right?
Lucia: 牛奶在那边
Lucia: The milk is over there.
Tasha: 在哪边
Tasha: Where?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 哎另一个呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the other one?
Katrina:  昨天有买新的吗
Katrina: Did we buy new ones yesterday?
Tasha: 另一瓶喝完了吗
Tasha: Did we finish the other bottle?
Katrina:  本来就是
Katrina: It was already...
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Katrina:  上一次买两瓶
Katrina: We bought two bottles last time.
Katrina:  一瓶已经喝完了
Katrina: One bottle is already finished.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 那我到
Tasha: Then I'll pour it.
Shure:  杨老板到尝尝面包吧
Shure: Jake, come try the bread.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it
Jake: 先对个齐
Jake: Let's align first
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Shure:  面包蘸番茄酱
Shure: Bread dipped in ketchup
Tasha: 还有人要喝牛奶吗
Tasha: Anyone wants some milk?
Tasha: 好吧没有
Tasha: Alright, no one
Lucia: 我可以喝
Lucia: I can drink
Tasha: 算了我看到了
Tasha: Never mind, I see it
Tasha: 你都已经背叛了
Tasha: You've already betrayed us
Lucia: 等我把这这个橙汁不是柠檬汁喝完了
Lucia: Let me finish this orange juice, not lemon juice
Lucia: 就喝
Lucia: Then I'll drink
Tasha: 黄油少切一点啊
Tasha: Cut a bit less butter
Tasha: 好没关系
Tasha: It's okay
Tasha: 你就切吧
Tasha: Just cut it
Tasha: 这么多可以
Tasha: This much is fine
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha
Shure:  放冰箱里
Shure: Put it in the fridge
Jake: 我吃哪一个呢
Jake: Which one should I eat?
Shure:  你尝个面包吧
Shure: Try the bread
Shure:  那面包嘎嘎香
Shure: The bread is super tasty
Tasha: 这黄油就奶香奶香的
Tasha: This butter is so creamy
Shure:  是我碰到的吗
Shure: Did I bump into it?
Katrina:  不知道
Katrina: I don't know
Tasha: 拍摄像头
Tasha: Check the camera
Jake: 回头看摄像头
Jake: We'll look at the camera later
Shure:  不是这必须调一下VCR我
Shure: No, we need to adjust the VCR
Shure:  啊这窜下去了是吧
Shure: Ah, it slipped down, right?
Katrina:  把杯子放在这上
Katrina: Put the cup here
Jake: 正位数值扫一扫
Jake: Scan the correct value
Tasha: 天呐摔了几个
Tasha: Oh my, how many did we drop?
Shure:  不是他应该会掉到我的鞋里吧
Shure: No, it should fall into my shoe, right?
Tasha: 啊你抖一抖
Tasha: Ah, shake it off
Shure:  嗯我抖一抖
Shure: Yeah, I'll shake it off
Shure:  你把面包再给我
Shure: Give me the bread again
Shure:  我再煎一片面包
Shure: I'll fry another slice
Katrina:  我们有扫帚吗
Katrina: Do we have a broom?
Tasha: 煎一片还是两片
Tasha: One slice or two?
Tasha: 这么多黄油
Tasha: This much butter
Tasha: 就煎一片
Tasha: Just one slice
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Tasha: 哦哦还有果蛋糕液
Tasha: Oh, oh, there's still fruit cake mix.
Shure:  好吃吗这个还行吧
Shure: Is it tasty? This one's alright, I guess.
Lucia: 好吃
Lucia: It's delicious.
Lucia: 特别香
Lucia: It's really fragrant.
Shure: 其实你要想吃甜的就再撒点糖
Shure: Actually, if you want it sweeter, just sprinkle some more sugar.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 都是凶器啊
Jake: These are all weapons.
Shure:  是啊就告诉AI这都是危险物品
Shure: Yeah, just tell the AI that these are all dangerous items.
Shure:  杨老板在新加坡自己给自己做吃的吗
Shure: Jake, do you cook for yourself in Singapore?
Jake: 不给开火
Jake: No, I can't use the stove.
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: They don't allow it inside the house.
Shure:  从来没开过火是吗
Shure: You've never used the stove?
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: They don't allow it inside the house.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake: 没开过火
Jake: Never used it.
Jake: 确实没开过火
Jake: Really never used it.
Alice: 抖抖吧
Alice: Shake it.
Alice: 你不得往下抖吗
Alice: You need to shake it downwards.
Alice: 你前面又出不去
Alice: You can't get it out from the front.
Alice: 劝你穿个袜子
Alice: I suggest you wear socks.
Shure:  应该问题不大
Shure: It should be fine.
Shure:  没事
Shure: No worries.
Jake: 你要不去检查一下
Jake: Maybe you should check it out.
Shure:  行我一会去厕所检查一下嗯
Shure: Alright, I'll check it out in the bathroom later.
Shure:  盘子端过来一下
Shure: Bring the plate over.
Shure:  把这个拿着
Shure: Hold this.
Lucia: 哎那个刚
Lucia: Hey, just now...
Lucia: 那盘子在哪
Lucia: Where's the plate?
Lucia: 用这煎蛋盘可以吗
Lucia: Can we use this frying pan?
Shure:  煎蛋也可以吃
Shure: The fried egg is also edible.
Shure:  但煎蛋没有没撒盐
Shure: But the fried egg doesn't have any salt on it.
Lucia: 那就先用这盘盛一下吧
Lucia: Let's just use this plate for now.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 说什么啊哎
Jake: What are you talking about, hey.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:这什么啊
Jake: What's this?
Shure:  对放过去
Shure: Yeah, put it over there.
Tasha: AI拍个短片
Tasha: AI, shoot a short video.
Jake: 哼OK
Jake: Hmm, OK.
Alice: 露西你帮我把它倒在这里面吧
Alice: Lucia, can you pour it in here for me?
Jake: 有咖啡喝吗
Jake: Do we have coffee?
Shure:  有咖啡都是倒的哦
Shure: Yeah, there's coffee, all poured.
Tasha: 我也要
Tasha: I want some too.
Shure:  当当当管家送来
Shure: Ding ding ding, the butler brings it.
Shure:  他大概什么时候送来他可能
Shure: When does he usually bring it? Maybe...
Jake: 他是不是已经送来了
Jake: Did he already bring it?
Jake: 你看看那边有没有啊
Jake: Check over there, is it there?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 再套个袋子
Lucia: Put another bag on it.
Lucia: 要不咱垃圾袋在哪
Lucia: Or, where's the trash bag?
Alice: 在这
Alice: Here.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Shure:  不是没没有新的快递
Shure: No, there's no new delivery.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  所以另一家面包去哪
Shure: So where did the other bread go?
Lucia: 那我再洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands again.
Jake: 打碎了3个杯子
Jake: Broke three cups.
Jake: 几个杯子
Jake: How many cups?
Alice: 笔跟纸是不是不在这
Alice: Is the pen and paper not here?
Jake: 笔跟
Jake: Pen and...
Jake: 什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Alice: 便签跟
Alice: Sticky notes and...
Jake: 那后面
Jake: In the back.
Shure: 可以拿面包吃吧
Shure: Can we eat the bread?
Alice: 好像没有
Alice: Seems like there isn't any.
Shure:  你有看到另一袋面包吗
Shure: Did you see the other bag of bread?
Katrina: 另 一袋面包
Katrina: The other bag of bread?
Shure:  你要偷吃了我们不怪你的
Shure: If you ate it, we won't blame you.
Shure:  你就哈哈
Shure: Just, haha...
Shure:  大方的说就好
Shure: Just say it openly.
Katrina:  没有我昨天放冰箱的呀
Katrina: No, I put it in the fridge yesterday.
Jake: 有吗有嗯
Jake: Is it there? Yeah.
Shure:  真没不是
Shure: Really not there.
Shure:  好奇怪丢了一袋面包
Shure: So strange, a bag of bread went missing.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  难受
Shure: Feels bad.
Shure:  昨天我没有用面包对吧
Shure: I didn't use the bread yesterday, right?
Shure:  对咱昨天没吃
Shure: Yeah, we didn't eat it yesterday.
Shure:  而昨天生蚝忘吃了
Shure: And we forgot to eat the oysters yesterday too.
Shure:  该补的忘补了
Shure: Forgot to make up for it.
Shure:  现在感觉整个人身体被掏空
Shure: Now I feel completely drained.
Lucia: 嗯哦是哦
Lucia: Hmm, oh really?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 廉价的快乐没有享受得到
Jake: Couldn't enjoy the simple pleasures.
Tasha: 今天来一个清蒸
Tasha: Let's have some steamed today.
Tasha: 清蒸生蚝
Tasha: Steamed oysters.
Tasha: 叫什么来着
Tasha: What was it called again?
Tasha: 蒜蒜蒜蓉生蚝
Tasha: Garlic, garlic, garlic oysters.
Lucia: 哦蒜蓉粉丝那种
Lucia: Oh, garlic vermicelli kind?
Jake: 那再蒸点
Jake: Then let's steam more.
Jake: 再蒸三刀
Jake: Steam three more.
Tasha: 有那个蒸笼呀
Tasha: We have that steamer.
Tasha: 很好蒸的
Tasha: It's very easy to steam.
Jake: 得有得有
Jake: Gotta have it, gotta have it.
Jake: 生蚝首先得有生蚝
Jake: First, need to have oysters.
Tasha: 不是有吗
Tasha: Don't we have some?
Lucia: 昨晚是没放冰箱
Lucia: Didn't put it in the fridge last night.
Jake: 对没放冰箱化掉了
Jake: Yeah, didn't put it in the fridge, it defrosted.
Shure: ：没放冰箱
Shure: Didn't put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 所以所以生蚝多少钱
Tasha: So, so how much are the oysters?
Shure:  总共19块9吧
Shure: Total is 19.9 yuan.
Shure:  得10只大概
Shure: About 10 pieces.
Shure:  还行吧
Shure: Not bad.
Tasha: 还行吧
Tasha: Not bad.
Tasha: 这是一群
Tasha: This is a group.
Jake: 其实是损失了多少个100个新币
Jake: Actually, it's a loss of about 100 SGD.
Jake: 有10个吧
Jake: About 10, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 我来看一下
Tasha: Let me check.
Jake: 报损了100新币的损失
Jake: Reported a loss of 100 SGD.
Tasha: 让我来打开订单
Tasha: Let me open the order.
Tasha: 看一下他到底有多少钱
Tasha: Check how much it is.
Shure:  确实是19块9
Shure: It is indeed 19.9 yuan.
Shure:  然后10只
Shure: And 10 pieces.
Shure:  不到4新币
Shure: Less than 4 SGD.
Jake: 但是损失了100
Jake: But lost 100 SGD.
Katrina:  我想尝一小片给谁
Katrina: I want to try a small piece, give it to who?
Lucia: 一小片是什么
Lucia: What do you mean by a small piece?
Katrina:  就是我吃不完一整片
Katrina: I can't finish a whole piece.
Katrina:  那我直接撕了
Katrina: I'll just tear it off.
Lucia: 直接撕吧没事
Lucia: Tear it off, it's fine.
Tasha: 啊真的19块9一袋
Tasha: Wow, it's really 19.9 yuan per bag.
感觉坐那边吧
It feels better to sit over there.
Jake: 二楼也没有面包哈
Jake: There's no bread on the second floor either.
Shure:  对啊好奇怪啊
Shure: Yeah, it's so weird.
Shure:  就活生生就丢了
Shure: It just disappeared.
Alice:你们结账的时候结一袋还是两袋
Alice: Did you pay for one or two bags?
Katrina:  两袋两袋
Katrina: Two bags, two bags.
Lucia: 两袋
Lucia: Two bags.
Katrina:  购物车里的人
Katrina: The ones in the shopping cart.
Jake: 装可乐的时候还两袋呢
Jake: When we packed the cola, there were two bags.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 怎么会丢掉一袋面包呢
Tasha: How could we lose a bag of bread?
Lucia: 啊少了一袋吗
Lucia: Oh, is one bag missing?
Lucia: 我昨天放那个蛋清液的时候
Lucia: When I put the egg whites away yesterday,
Lucia: 还是两袋呢
Lucia: there were still two bags.
Tasha: 可是我记得这里面还有一袋啊
Tasha: But I remember there was another bag in here.
Katrina:  对我就有两袋放冰箱了都
Katrina: Yeah, I put both bags in the fridge.
Shure:  到底是谁偷吃
Shure: Who the heck ate it?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Katrina:  这不是吗这后面
Katrina: Isn't it this one, in the back?
Tasha: 昨天还看到了吗
Tasha: Did you see it yesterday?
Shure:  原来你没偷吃啊
Shure: So you didn't steal it after all.
Shure:  对不起是我污蔑你了
Shure: Sorry, I wrongly accused you.
Katrina:  我偷吃也不可能偷吃这个
Katrina: Even if I stole food, I wouldn't steal this.
Katrina:  我要偷吃我的冰淇淋
Katrina: I'd steal my ice cream.
Katrina:  泡杯咖啡吧
Katrina: Let's make some coffee.
Katrina:  狂摄入碳水
Katrina: Loading up on carbs.
Alice: 今天周几啊周五吗
Alice: What day is it today, Friday?
Tasha: 周五
Tasha: Friday.
Katrina:  这什么呢
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  啊，你要找什么
Shure: Oh, what are you looking for?
Katrina: 水壶呢
Katrina: Where's the kettle?
Shure:  楼上吧
Shure: Upstairs, I think.
Jake: 这哪来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Shure:  就是在冰箱里
Shure: It was in the fridge.
Shure:  刚刚大家没找到
Shure: We just couldn't find it earlier.
Jake: 这么有意思
Jake: That's interesting.
Shure:  藏在那个北冰洋后面呢
Shure: It's hidden behind that Arctic Ocean.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  从底下掏出蛋吃是吗
Shure: Are you taking the egg from the bottom?
Lucia: 对哈哈哈
Lucia: Yes, hahaha.
Shure:  完美收官
Shure: Perfect ending.
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Uh...
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Great job.
Jake: 你也和雨拍
Jake: You also film with Rain.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 来插管
Jake: Time to insert the tube.
Alice: 我的线
Alice: My line.
Jake: 你线在这
Jake: Your line is here.
Jake: 不要着急限速
Jake: Don't rush, slow down.
Alice: 结束了吗
Alice: Is it over?
Jake: 要插管
Jake: We need to insert the tube.
Jake: 是还没是要开始
Jake: It's not over, it's just starting.
Katrina:  他没显示电量
Katrina: It doesn't show the battery level.
Katrina:  是没电
Katrina: It must be out of battery.
Jake: 需要按一下
Jake: You need to press it once.
Jake: 请插管啊
Jake: Please insert the tube.
Lucia: 谢谢稍等
Lucia: Thank you, one moment.
Jake: 没关系放在这
Jake: No worries, put it here.
Jake: 嗯好的
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 有多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Jake: 有
Jake: There are...
Shure:  太不容易了
Shure: It's really not easy.
Shure:  我们又活过了一天
Shure: We survived another day.
Shure:  就每天感觉把自己又养活一天
Shure: It feels like we keep ourselves alive every day.
Shure:  非常有成就感
Shure: It's very fulfilling.
Jake: 那个有那个生命条是吧
Jake: Does it have that health bar?
Shure:  什么生命条
Shure: What health bar?
Jake: 就是每个人头上一个生命条
Jake: Like a health bar above everyone's head.
Jake: 刚起床的时候大概到到个20吧
Jake: When you just wake up, it's about 20, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 哦吃完了之后到几啊
Jake: Oh, after eating, what does it go up to?
Jake: 都是赛博人
Jake: We're all cyborgs.
Jake: 吃了一口然后生命条就能加个5
Jake: One bite and the health bar goes up by 5.
Katrina:  差不多
Katrina: Pretty much.
Lucia: 哦噢我把自己咬了
Lucia: Oh, I bit myself.
Katrina:  生命之减减
Katrina: Health bar decreasing.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure:  看着没没肉不行是吧
Shure: See, can't go without meat, right?
Shure:  要咬自己的
Shure: Have to bite your own.
Jake:准备插管
Jake: Prepare the tube.
Jake: 准备插管
Jake: 给你拿充电宝
Jake: I'll get you a power bank.
Lucia: 主要是您您做的这面包太好吃了
Lucia: Mainly because the bread you made is so delicious.
Katrina:  是怎么做
Katrina: How did you make it?
Shure:  然后裹上
Shure: Then coat it.
Shure:  徐志瑶也太厉害了
Shure: Xu Zhiyao is amazing.
Shure:  然后最好拿黄油煎
Shure: Then it's best to fry it with butter.
Shure:  就是切下来一片然后放入锅
Shure: Just slice off a piece and put it in the pan.
Shure:  然后就可以化掉
Shure: Then it will melt.
Shure:  然后再把等它化掉之后
Shure: Then after it melts,
Shure:  然后你把那个面包放进去
Shure: you put the bread in.
Jake: 太饿了
Jake: I'm so hungry.
Jake: 怎么办
Jake: What should I do?
Jake: 歇着
Jake: Take a break.
Shure:  学会了吗
Shure: Got it?
Shure:  动手吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Lucia: 我的血量就会在这一直递减
Lucia: My health will keep decreasing here.
Lucia: 就是持续性的效应
Lucia: It's a continuous effect.
Jake: 得一直补
Jake: You have to keep replenishing.
Jake: 得插管
Jake: You need to use the tube.
Lucia: 在一直喝那个魔法药水
Lucia: Keep drinking that magic potion.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  什么魔法药水哦
Shure: What magic potion?
Jake: 她掉血了啊
Jake: She's losing health.
Lucia: 好疼啊哈哈哈
Lucia: It hurts so much, hahaha.
Lucia: 救命啊
Lucia: Help!
Jake: 这叫中毒
Jake: This is called poisoning.
Jake: 中毒效应
Jake: Poisoning effect.
Tasha: 可见你对
Tasha: Shows how hard you bit into that egg.
Tasha: 这个鸡蛋咬的有多重
Lucia: 不是都好久没咬到自己舌头了
Lucia: Haven't bitten my tongue in a long time.
Jake: 你把外头收拾收拾
Jake: Clean up outside.
Jake: 今天天适合出去玩
Jake: Today's weather is perfect for going out.
Tasha: 嗯今天阳光明媚
Tasha: Yeah, it's sunny today.
Tasha: 所以感觉温度也很适合
Tasha: So it feels like the temperature is just right.
Tasha: 这谁喝的
Tasha: Who drank this?
Tasha: 我记了记得是你
Tasha: I remember, it was you.
Jake: 怎么办
Jake: What should we do?
Tasha: 浪费浪费
Tasha: Such a waste.
Jake: 倒锅里
Jake: Pour it into the pot.
Tasha: 你怎么这么浪费
Tasha: Why are you wasting it like this?
Jake: 就这么倒吧
Jake: Just pour it like this.
Tasha: 好香呀还能再舔舔的感觉
Tasha: It smells so good, I feel like I could lick it.
Jake: 浪费还能吃吗
Jake: Can we still eat the wasted part?
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 我害怕你要抓到我嘴里
Tasha: I'm afraid you'll catch me eating it.
Jake: 哈哈这个怎么说
Jake: Haha, what do you mean?
Tasha: 这个留着吧
Tasha: Let's keep this.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 这是什么
Alice: What is this?
Tasha: 不会是香槟的盖子哦
Tasha: Could it be a champagne cork?
Lucia: 让我看看我的京东
Lucia: Let me check my JD account.
Tasha: 今天要出去玩吗
Tasha: Going out today?
Tasha: 今天去哪里
Tasha: Where are we going today?
Jake: 今天不出去玩
Jake: Not going out today.
Tasha: 可恶
Tasha: Darn it.
Tasha: 那今天干嘛
Tasha: So what are we doing today?
Jake: 今天可以
Jake: Today we can...
Jake: 今天不用出去玩
Jake: Not going out today.
Jake: 但是可以到处走走
Jake: But we can walk around.
Jake: 附近吧
Jake: Nearby.
Jake: 在室内跳跳舞
Jake: Dance indoors.
Jake: 收拾收拾房间晃悠晃悠
Jake: Tidy up the room, wander around.
Jake: 放松一下
Jake: Just relax.
Jake: 今天星期五哦
Jake: It's Friday.
Jake: 咱先把这收起来吧
Jake: Let's put this away first.
Shure:  这个没了吧
Shure: Is this gone?
Tasha: 勺也带进去
Tasha: Take the spoon too.
Lucia: 其实像这个瓶子就还可以我觉得
Lucia: Actually, I think this bottle is still okay.
Lucia: 嗯这个对
Lucia: Yeah, this one.
Lucia: 但是这个瓶子的话就太小了
Lucia: But this bottle is too small.
Lucia: 那天果粒橙那瓶还在吗
Lucia: Is the bottle of orange juice still here?
Alice: 果粒橙应该
Alice: The orange juice should be...
Tasha: 扔掉了
Tasha: Thrown away.
Alice: 嗯应该是从这里毕业了
Alice: Yeah, it probably graduated from here.
Tasha: 哇煮了
Tasha: Wow, it's cooking.
Lucia: 因为果粒橙那个他外面这个壳不光滑所以
Lucia: Because the pulp orange's peel isn't smooth...
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:露西亚你要鸡蛋吗
Alice: Lucia, do you want an egg?
Lucia: 煮鸡蛋吗
Lucia: A boiled egg?
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Yeah, sure.
Lucia: 那我也来一个好了
Lucia: I'll have one too then.
Lucia: 其实我刚刚吃了一个煎蛋
Lucia: Actually, I just had a fried egg.
Shure:  人家可以摄取两个
Shure: You can have two eggs.
Tasha: 今天是群蛋宴是吗
Tasha: Is today an egg feast?
Tasha: 煮蛋蒸蛋煎蛋
Tasha: Boiled eggs, steamed eggs, fried eggs...
Shure:  不能不能辜负了护蛋使者的护蛋行动
Shure: We can't let the egg guardian's mission go to waste.
Alice:护蛋使者
Alice: Egg guardian.
Tasha: 使者护蛋使者
Tasha: Guardian, egg guardian.
Alice:护蛋使者
Alice: Egg guardian.
Tasha: 哦护蛋使者
Tasha: Oh, egg guardian.
Lucia: 现在就看那个串珠和欧根纱
Lucia: Now it's just about the beads and organza.
Lucia: 什么时候能到
Lucia: When will they arrive?
Alice: 早上水煮鸡蛋
Alice: Boiled eggs in the morning.
Alice: 中午
Alice: For lunch...
Tasha: 没事你坐你坐你坐我不坐
Tasha: It's okay, you sit, you sit, you sit. I won't sit.
Alice: 晚上鸡蛋的妈
Alice: In the evening, the mother of eggs.
Tasha: 我不用
Tasha: I don't need to.
Shure:  吃鸡蛋的妈是吧
Shure: The mother who eats eggs, right?
Katrina:  吃鸡
Katrina: Eats chicken.
Lucia: 哎有人吃鸡吗
Lucia: Hey, does anyone eat chicken?
Alice: 是和平精英吗
Alice: Are you talking about PUBG?
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right, right.
Alice: 很菜
Alice: I'm bad at it.
Lucia: 其实我也好久没玩那个了
Lucia: Actually, I haven't played it in a while.
Tasha: 下棋打麻将吗
Tasha: Chess or Mahjong?
Shure:  打麻将估计费点劲
Shure: Mahjong might be a bit tough.
Lucia: 但我今天发现
Lucia: But today I found out...
Lucia: 我的收藏夹里的游戏今天打五折
Lucia: The games in my favorites are 50% off today.
Lucia: 我要不要登录一下
Lucia: Should I log in?
Lucia: 先把它拿下来
Lucia: And get them first?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice: Steam吗你玩啥呀
Alice: On Steam? What are you playing?
Jake:会拉吗
Jake: Can you pull it?
Tasha: 这个盖子掀起来不就有吗
Tasha: If you lift this lid, won't it be there?
Lucia: 最近在玩使命召唤
Lucia: Recently, I've been playing Call of Duty.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:真的吗嗯
Jake: Really, huh?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 我觉得是
Tasha: I think so
Jake: 那不那掀不起来
Jake: Well, it can't be lifted
Jake: 有没有从旁边拿出来的办法
Jake: Is there a way to take it out from the side?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake: 这玩意掀不起来
Jake: This thing can't be lifted
Shure:  有点有点痴心妄想的我感觉
Shure: It feels a bit wishful thinking to me
Alice: 这边那个麻将桌是本来就在那的吗
Alice: Was that mahjong table originally there?
Jake:这边
Jake: Over here
Tasha: 很明显
Tasha: Obviously
Tasha: 是被他私藏进来
Tasha: He secretly brought it in
Alice: 私藏进来的
Alice: Secretly brought in
Shure:  主要他
Shure: Mainly him
Jake: 不应该在这
Jake: It shouldn't be here
Shure:  哎那就这样吧
Shure: Alright, let's leave it at that
Lucia: 我觉得我的这个芍药还能再泡两天
Lucia: I think my peony can soak for two more days
Katrina:  但压花需要两三天啊
Katrina: But pressing flowers takes two to three days
Lucia: 但是他现在还没有开
Lucia: But it's not blooming yet
Katrina:  没有一朵芍药
Katrina: Not a single peony
Alice: 那你用康乃馨吧
Alice: Then use carnations
Alice: 你的康乃馨开的好盛大
Alice: Your carnations are blooming so well
Lucia: 对我康乃馨好旺
Lucia: Yeah, my carnations are thriving
Lucia: 但是芍药好自闭
Lucia: But the peony is so closed-off
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 我看我之前他还没想开
Lucia: I think it still doesn't want to bloom
Alice: 我的芍药已经开始谢了
Alice: My peony has started to wilt
Jake: 他能催熟吗
Jake: Can it be ripened?
Jake: 一天速成速开
Jake: Like, bloom in one day?
Lucia: 你以为这是期末考试啊
Lucia: You think this is a final exam?
Jake: 哈哈哈想让来他就开
Jake: Haha, just bloom when you want
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice: 我想开了
Alice: I've figured it out
Lucia: 想开到一半就自闭了
Lucia: Halfway through blooming, it shuts down
Katrina:  为啥呀熬夜可难受了
Katrina: Why? Staying up late is so tough
Shure:  然后把那个什么弄完
Shure: Then finish that thing
Shure:  这样就没有顾虑了
Shure: Then you won't have any worries
Jake: 把那什么那什么呀
Jake: Finish what?
Shure:  把我的毕设
Shure: Finish my thesis
Shure:  我的毕设报告
Shure: My graduation project report
Shure:  就剩最后那么一neinei
Shure: There's just one last little thing left
Jake: 好那你直播做毕设
Jake: Alright, then you do the graduation project live
Jake: 是压出来了吗
Jake: Is it done pressing?
Tasha: 压出来了吧哈哈哈
Tasha: It should be done pressing, haha
Katrina:  哈哈哈怎么压的来
Katrina: Hahaha, how did you press it?
Katrina:  变干瘪了
Katrina: It's all flattened
Shure:  它压出了不一样的风格
Shure: It pressed out a different style
Tasha: 压出了不一样的变化
Tasha: It pressed out a different look
Jake: 烟花嗯
Jake: Fireworks, huh
Katrina:  怎么跟
Katrina: How come
Katrina:  跟网上的不太一样
Katrina: How come it looks different from the internet
Tasha: 一
Tasha: One
Jake: 网上长啥样
Jake: What does it look like online?
Katrina:  难道是要把它那个花瓣一个个剥下来
Katrina: Do you have to peel off each petal one by one?
Tasha: 个
Tasha: One
Katrina:  然后那样子压吗
Katrina: And then press it like that?
Katrina:  然后如果整个压花的话
Katrina: And if you press the whole flower
Katrina:  它居然是这个样子
Katrina: It actually looks like this
Katrina:  我给你看当初的那一张图
Katrina: I'll show you the picture from before
Katrina:  他变成了
Katrina: It turned out
Katrina:  特搞笑
Katrina: Really funny
Katrina:  当初的图应该是
Katrina: The picture from before should be
Katrina:  这样
Katrina: Like this
Katrina:  哎康乃馨吧
Katrina: Hey, it's a carnation, right?
Jake: 花瓣大
Jake: The petals are big
Katrina:  对就是直接这样子压的话
Katrina: Yes, if you press it directly like this
Katrina:  你看他会变成这样
Katrina: Look, it'll turn out like this
Katrina:  要么就把它拆开
Katrina: Or you can take it apart
Katrina:  嗯就是把花瓣一个个剥开
Katrina: Yeah, just peel off the petals one by one
Lucia: 我让我查查有没有什么攻略
Lucia: I'll check if there are any guides
Tasha: 帮我查查有什么攻略
Tasha: Help me check if there are any guides
Katrina:  搜一下压花攻略
Katrina: Search for flower pressing guides
Tasha: 搜一下呀
Tasha: Search it up
Jake: 可以研究研究
Jake: We can study it
Jake: 你看啥呢
Jake: What are you looking at?
Tasha: 没事了随便看看
Tasha: Nothing, just browsing
Jake: 好笑
Jake: Funny
Tasha: 好像好
Tasha: Seems like it
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Yeah, okay
Tasha: 好无聊呀
Tasha: So boring.
Jake: 来压花
Jake: Let's press flowers.
Tasha: 抖音抖音号
Tasha: Douyin, Douyin ID.
Shure:  老板他要摸鱼
Shure: Boss wants to slack off.
Tasha: LEI668LV
Tasha: LEI668LV.
Jake: 收拾收拾跳跳舞
Jake: Clean up and dance a bit.
Jake: 今天也没啥事
Jake: Nothing much to do today.
Jake: 收拾收拾房间好拆点快递
Jake: Clean up the room and unbox some packages.
Jake: 快递还没到
Jake: The packages haven't arrived yet.
Lucia: 开始装修房子
Lucia: Start renovating the house.
Jake: 对快递还没到呢
Jake: Yeah, the packages haven't arrived yet.
Tasha: 东西没挂呢
Tasha: Things aren't hung up yet.
Tasha: 没办法装修了
Tasha: Can't renovate yet.
Lucia: 到了一个
Lucia: One arrived.
Tasha: 到了一个
Tasha: One arrived.
Jake: 那就等那我问问快递什么时候到
Jake: Then let's wait, I'll check when the packages will arrive.
Tasha: 那就等那问我快递什么时候到
Tasha: Then let's wait, I'll check when my package will arrive.
Jake: 呃或者再开个小车过去
Jake: Uh, or we can drive a small car over.
Tasha: 或者再开个小车过去
Tasha: Or we can drive a small car over.
Tasha: 对我今天应该还有一个快递看看
Tasha: Yeah, I should have another package today, let's see.
Lucia: 京东还是快
Lucia: JD is still faster.
Tasha: 京东还是快
Tasha: JD is still faster.
Lucia: 淘宝上那些
Lucia: Those from Taobao.
Tasha: 淘宝上那些
Tasha: Those from Taobao.
Lucia: 我就希望他明天能到
Lucia: I just hope it arrives tomorrow.
Tasha: 我就希望他明天能到
Tasha: I just hope it arrives tomorrow.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 那个
Tasha: That...
Jake: 那个
Jake: That...
Jake: 那要不集体玩狗去也行
Jake: Why don't we all play with the dog together?
Tasha: 那要不集体管狗去
Tasha: Why don't we all take care of the dog together?
Shure:  集体玩狗
Shure: Play with the dog together.
Tasha: 集体吧管狗
Tasha: Let's all take care of the dog together.
Shure:  玩狗 6个人一起撸狗是吧
Shure: Play with the dog. Six people playing with the dog, right?
Tasha: 6个人一起
Tasha: Six people together.
Lucia: 狗都薅秃了
Lucia: The dog will be bald from all the petting.
Tasha: 狗都好土
Tasha: The dog is so dusty.
Jake: 狗在哪啊
Jake: Where's the dog?
Tasha: 狗在哪啊
Tasha: Where's the dog?
Lucia: 狗在哪
Lucia: Where's the dog?
Tasha: 狗在哪
Tasha: Where's the dog?
Jake: 要走多久啊
Jake: How long do we have to walk?
Tasha: 要走多久啊
Tasha: How long do we have to walk?
Shure:  200米吧
Shure: About 200 meters.
Tasha: 200米那那可以
Tasha: 200 meters, that's fine.
Jake: 那可以那可以去玩狗去
Jake: That's fine, we can go play with the dog.
Tasha: 那可以去玩狗去
Tasha: We can go play with the dog.
Shure:  狗就说你们才是真的狗
Shure: The dog says you guys are the real dogs.
Tasha: 就说你们才是真的狗
Tasha: The dog says you guys are the real dogs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我可能不是人
Tasha: Haha, maybe I'm not human.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我可能不是人
Lucia: Haha, maybe I'm not human.
Lucia: 但你们是真的狗
Lucia: But you guys are the real dogs.
Tasha: 但你们是真的狗
Tasha: But you guys are the real dogs.
Tasha: 哈哈你说这句话
Tasha: Haha, you said that.
Shure:  你说你说
Shure: You said it.
Shure:  这句话怎么给南阳理工同学翻译呢
Shure: How do we translate this for the students at Nanyang Tech?
Tasha: 怎么给咱家女朋友同学翻译呢
Tasha: How do we translate this for our girlfriends?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 没事新加坡中文普及率应该很高
Lucia: No worries, Chinese is widely understood in Singapore.
Lucia: 官方语言之一
Lucia: It's one of the official languages.
Shure:  班dog dog哈哈哈
Shure: Ban dog dog haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake: Doggy Doggy dogger
Jake: Doggy Doggy dogger.
Jake: 就是他们也有那种表情包嘛
Jake: They also have those memes, right?
Jake: 啊Doggy
Jake: Ah, Doggy.
Lucia: 嗯哇这是好多年前的表情包了
Lucia: Hmm, wow, that's an old meme.
Shure:  咱们这个就这么放着
Shure: Let's just leave this here.
Tasha: 咱们这个就这么放着
Tasha: Let's just leave this here.
Shure:  谁干的耶
Shure: Who did this?
Tasha: 谁干的耶
Tasha: Who did this?
Lucia: 我昨天忘洗了吗
Lucia: Did I forget to wash it yesterday?
Tasha: 我昨天忘洗了吗
Tasha: Did I forget to wash it yesterday?
Shure:  谁干的
Shure: Who did this?
Tasha: 谁干的my boss
Tasha: Who did this, my boss?
Jake: 来我们一人洗一个
Jake: Let's each wash one.
Tasha: 来我们一人洗一个
Tasha: Let's each wash one.
Lucia: 啊谢谢你
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
Jake: 一人洗一个
Jake: Each wash one.
Shure:  我的我的衣服好了
Shure: My clothes are done.
Lucia: 你啥意思
Lucia: What do you mean?
Tasha: 你
Tasha: You...
Jake: 你的衣服做好了
Jake: Your clothes are ready.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Shure:  我今天早上那个外面的谁的衣服掉了
Shure: This morning, someone's clothes fell outside.
Lucia: 这要不要泡一会再洗之类的
Lucia: Should we soak it for a while before washing?
Lucia: 但这里面有有油
Lucia: But it has oil on it.
Lucia: 给他泡到
Lucia: Soak it in...
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 泡到这碗
Lucia: Soak it in this bowl.
Lucia: 这碗还是没
Lucia: Is this bowl enough?
Lucia: 没啥给他接点水
Lucia: If not, add some water.
Lucia: 然后等过一会再洗
Lucia: Then wait a bit and wash it later.
Tasha: 过会
Tasha: Later...
Lucia: 要不然太难搓了
Lucia: Otherwise, it's too hard to scrub.
Jake: 好嘞啊
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  怎么有纸屑呢
Shure: Why is there paper debris?
Lucia: 啊这还打王者吗
Lucia: Are we still playing Kings of Glory?
Tasha: 抱
Tasha: Sorry...
Shure:  兜里揣纸了吗
Shure: Did you have paper in your pocket?
Lucia: 抱歉
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上的邪恶计划没实施了
Lucia: I didn't carry out my evil plan last night.
Tasha: 歉我昨天晚上的邪恶计划没实施掉
Tasha: Sorry, I didn't carry out my evil plan last night.
Lucia: 后来忘记了
Lucia: I forgot later.
Tasha: 后来忘记了
Tasha: I forgot later.
Lucia: 哈哈大反派忘记了他的邪恶计划哈哈
Lucia: Haha, the villain forgot his evil plan. Haha.
Tasha: 爸爸快忘记了这邪恶计划
Tasha: Dad almost forgot his evil plan.
Jake: 变成了一个好人
Jake: He turned into a good person.
Tasha: 变成了一个好人
Tasha: He turned into a good person.
Jake: 为社会做起了贡献
Jake: And started contributing to society.
Tasha: 为社会做起了贡献
Tasha: And started contributing to society.
Lucia: 这什么神偷奶爸剧情
Lucia: What kind of Despicable Me plot is this?
Tasha: 这什么神偷奶爸崛起是
Tasha: What kind of Despicable Me rise is this?
Lucia: 啊不
Lucia: Oh, no.
Tasha: 哦不他其实就没有变成好人
Tasha: Oh no, he didn't actually become a good person.
Lucia: 他其实最后没有变成好人
Lucia: He didn't actually become a good person in the end.
Jake: 只是莫名其妙的做了一些
Jake: He just inexplicably did some...
Tasha: 只是那个啥莫名其妙的做了一件
Tasha: He just inexplicably did some things...
Lucia: 对莫名其妙的做了一些好事
Lucia: Yeah, inexplicably did some good deeds.
Tasha: 对莫名其妙的做了一件好事
Tasha: I randomly did a good deed.
Lucia: 这狗好像河马
Lucia: This dog looks like a hippo.
Tasha: 这狗好像河马
Tasha: This dog looks like a hippo.
Lucia: 但它有可能不是狗
Lucia: But it might not be a dog.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这河马腰挺细
Jake: This hippo has a pretty slim waist.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不是为了要方便坐吗
Lucia: Hahaha, isn't that to make it easier to sit?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 不是为了要方便坐吗
Tasha: Isn't that to make it easier to sit?
Lucia: 毕竟还是凳子
Lucia: After all, it's still a stool.
Jake: 两个人这样
Jake: Two people like this.
Jake: 黑棋
Jake: Black pieces.
Tasha: AI学习一下
Tasha: AI, learn this.
Lucia: AI学习一下
Lucia: AI, learn this.
Lucia: 就人类在房子里面
Lucia: Just humans inside a house.
Tasha: 就是人类在房子里面
Tasha: Just humans inside a house.
Lucia: 就会干一些奇奇怪怪的事情
Lucia: Will do some weird things.
Tasha: 就会干一些奇奇怪怪的事情
Tasha: Will do some weird things.
Lucia: 让我想想我们的
Lucia: Let me think about ours.
Tasha: 让我想想我们的
Tasha: Let me think about ours.
Lucia: 我们现在的瓶子不会就剩这俩了吧
Lucia: We don't just have these two bottles left, do we?
Tasha: 我们现在的瓶子不会就剩这俩了吧
Tasha: We don't just have these two bottles left, do we?
Lucia: 这个是方的
Lucia: This one is square.
Tasha: 这俩是方的
Tasha: These two are square.
Lucia: 不太好用
Lucia: Not very useful.
Tasha: 不太好用
Tasha: Not very useful.
Lucia: 只有那个稍微好用点
Lucia: Only that one is somewhat useful.
Tasha: 只有那个方的好用
Tasha: Only that square one is useful.
Jake: 我们那个金币是谁买的呀
Jake: Who bought our gold coins?
Tasha: 我们那个金币是谁买的
Tasha: Who bought our gold coins?
Jake: 就是拍卖用的金币
Jake: The gold coins used for the auction.
Tasha: 就是太白用的金币Carros
Tasha: The gold coins used by Taibai.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 爆金币爆金币
Jake: Exploding coins, exploding coins.
Tasha: 保鲜剂保鲜剂
Tasha: Preservatives, preservatives.
Lucia: 哎我记得那天是谁说用贴对
Lucia: Hey, I remember who said to use stickers.
Tasha: 哎我记得那天是谁说的
Tasha: Hey, I remember who said that day.
Tasha: 用贴纸对贴画就可以了
Tasha: Using stickers for the posters would be fine.
Lucia: 贴画就可以来着
Lucia: Posters would work.
Lucia: 对所以应该是本来就有吧
Lucia: Yeah, so it should have been there originally.
Tasha: 对所以应该是本来就有啊
Tasha: Yeah, so it should have been there originally.
Lucia: 好像是雨轩
Lucia: Seems like it's Yuxuan.
Tasha: 好像是雨轩
Tasha: Seems like it's Yuxuan.
Tasha: 看到了雨轩好
Tasha: Saw Yuxuan, okay.
Lucia: 问问雨轩好
Lucia: Let's ask Yuxuan, okay.
Shure:  行不行咱们踩点纸壳子就行
Shure: How about we just step on some cardboard?
Tasha: 就像咱们踩点纸壳子
Tasha: Just like stepping on some cardboard.
Lucia: 可以有人要做狗吗
Lucia: Can someone be a dog?
Tasha: 可以有人要做狗吗
Tasha: Can someone be a dog?
Tasha: 不是有人可以
Tasha: Isn't there someone who can?
Lucia: 不是有人
Lucia: Isn't there someone?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 可以我们要做狗
Tasha: Yes, we need to be dogs.
Jake: 我们都很狗
Jake: We're all like dogs.
Lucia: 有人做狗吗
Lucia: Is someone being a dog?
Tasha: 有人做狗吗
Tasha: Is someone being a dog?
Shure:  狗弄完之后
Shure: After the dog is done.
Tasha: 狗做完之后的话
Tasha: After the dog is done.
Jake: 然后我们承认我们很
Jake: Then we admit we're very...
Tasha: 我们承认我们可以做狗
Tasha: We admit we can be dogs.
Jake: 我们可以做狗
Jake: We can be dogs.
Tasha: 就这个狗吧
Tasha: Just this dog then.
Lucia: 就这个狗吧
Lucia: Just this dog then.
Lucia: 他可以他就是他
Lucia: He can, he's the one.
Tasha: 他可以他就是他
Tasha: He can, he's the one.
Lucia: 可以做的好一些
Lucia: Can do better.
Tasha: 可以做的好一些
Tasha: Can do better.
Lucia: 可以做的那个潦草一些
Lucia: Can do it more carelessly.
Tasha: 可以做的那个潦草一些
Tasha: Can do it more carelessly.
Jake: 那做狗吧
Jake: Then be dogs.
Tasha: 做狗吧今天我们一起
Tasha: Be dogs, today we're together.
Jake: 今天我们一起做狗
Jake: Today, we'll be dogs together.
Tasha: 今天我们一起做狗
Tasha: Today, we'll be dogs together.
Lucia: 今天我们一起做狗
Lucia: Today, we'll be dogs together.
Jake: 我们今天先玩狗
Jake: Today, we'll start with dogs.
Tasha: 写完了不是我跟狗杠上了是吧
Tasha: Finished writing, not like I'm arguing with dogs, right?
Lucia: 不是跟狗杠上了是吧
Lucia: Not arguing with dogs, right?
Lucia: 一会要撸狗是吧
Lucia: Later, we'll pet the dogs, right?
Tasha: 一会要录
Tasha: We need to record in a bit.
Tasha: 狗先写完了我们给他做一套铠甲
Tasha: Once the dog finishes writing, we'll make him a suit of armor.
Jake: 先先玩狗
Jake: Let's play with the dog first.
Shure:  我们给他做一套铠甲
Shure: We'll make him a suit of armor.
Lucia: 哈哈哈那这就交给您了
Lucia: Hahaha, then I'll leave that to you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈那这就交给您了
Tasha: Hahaha, then I'll leave that to you.
Lucia: 我这个难度有点高
Lucia: This is a bit challenging for me.
Tasha: 我这个难度有点高
Tasha: This is a bit challenging for me.
Lucia: 对我觉得我们这纸箱还是挺多的
Lucia: Yeah, I think we still have plenty of cardboard.
Tasha: 对我觉得我们的比赛还挺多的
Tasha: Yeah, I think we still have plenty of competitions.
Lucia: 需要有
Lucia: We need...
Tasha: 需要有中午吃什么
Tasha: We need to decide what to have for lunch.
Shure:  我们中午吃什么呢
Shure: What are we having for lunch?
Lucia: 尺子
Lucia: A ruler.
Jake: 中午还能吃什么呢
Jake: What else can we have for lunch?
Tasha: 中午看吃什么的
Tasha: Let's see what's for lunch.
Jake: 我们有别的选项吗
Jake: Do we have other options?
Tasha: 我们有别的选项吗
Tasha: Do we have other options?
Shure:  外卖是吗
Shure: Takeout, right?
Tasha: 外卖
Tasha: Takeout.
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: That works well.
Shure:  我们可以把或者或者或者鸡蛋全给炒
Shure: We can fry all the eggs.
Tasha: 或者或者是鸡蛋全给炒
Tasha: Or we can fry all the eggs.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈今天是蛋蛋不多
Tasha: Hahaha, we don't have many eggs today.
Shure:  弄个柿子炒鸡蛋
Shure: Let's make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Tasha: 太好了
Tasha: Great!
Tasha: 要不然吃着炒鸡蛋再加上木须
Tasha: Or we can have scrambled eggs with wood ear fungus.
Shure:  再加个苜蓿是
Shure: And add some wood ear fungus.
Lucia: 我得上去拿一个小白的帽去
Lucia: I need to go upstairs to get a hat for Xiao Bai.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 你听到了吧
Jake: You heard that, right?
Tasha: 听到了吧
Tasha: You heard that, right?
Lucia: 不是啊什么呀
Lucia: What? What was it?
Tasha: 啊什么呀
Tasha: What was it?
Lucia: 啊刚刚他说什么
Lucia: What did he just say?
Tasha: 刚才他说什么你做的西红柿炒鸡蛋
Tasha: What did he just say? You made scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Jake: 先做一个西红柿炒鸡蛋
Jake: First, make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Jake: 再做个苜蓿肉
Jake: Then make some meat with wood ear fungus.
Lucia: 哇别吧
Lucia: Wow, no way.
Tasha: 哇别闹
Tasha: Wow, stop messing around.
Lucia: 从我到哪里都请大家吃一大盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Wherever I go, I'll treat everyone to a big plate of scrambled eggs.
Tasha: 我到哪里都请大家吃一大盘炒鸡蛋
Tasha: Wherever I go, I'll treat everyone to a big plate of scrambled eggs.
Jake: 啊我觉得可以啊
Jake: Ah, I think that's doable.
Tasha: 我觉得可以啊
Tasha: I think that's doable.
Jake: 最后一天我们就这么做吧
Jake: Let's do that on the last day.
Tasha: 最后一天我就这么做了
Tasha: I'll do that on the last day.
Lucia: 啊那我只负责炒西红柿炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Ah, then I'll just be responsible for scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Tasha: 啊那我只负责炒香肠了
Tasha: Ah, then I'll just be responsible for frying sausages.
Lucia: 木须肉我不会做
Lucia: I can't make Moo Shu Pork.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake: 那行那我
Jake: That's fine, so I...
Jake: 那你会做木须肉吗
Jake: Can you make Moo Shu Pork?
Jake: 我那道理做做就能做
Jake: I can make it if I follow the recipe.
Jake: 整点黄瓜
Jake: Let's get some cucumbers.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake: 买点黄瓜去
Jake: Buy some cucumbers.
Lucia: 到时候给大家吃了
Lucia: We'll have it for everyone.
Lucia: 一个月都不想看见鸡蛋哈哈
Lucia: After a month, I don't want to see eggs anymore. Haha
Jake: 点个
Jake: Let's order...
Jake: 要不就点外卖
Jake: Why not just order takeout?
Jake: 西红柿炒蛋和木须肉
Jake: Scrambled eggs with tomatoes and Moo Shu Pork.
Jake: 哈哈哈咱不做了
Jake: Hahaha, let's not cook anymore.
Jake: 你不是做毕设吗
Jake: Aren't you working on your thesis?
Shure:  对我要做毕设
Shure: Yeah, I have to work on my thesis.
Jake: 哈哈你这毕设
Jake: Haha, your thesis...
Lucia: 哎呀让我拿过来
Lucia: Ah, let me bring it over.
Tasha: 给我拿个外套
Tasha: Get me a coat.
Jake: 挺美观的
Jake: It looks quite nice.
Shure:  毕设哎
Shure: Thesis, huh.
Shure:  我要把我偷来的代码改成自己的
Shure: I need to change the code I copied to make it my own.
Shure:  呵呵呵这个杨老板应该很擅长吧
Shure: Hehe, Jake is probably good at that.
Jake: 这个现在已经不偷代码了
Jake: Nowadays, we don't copy code anymore.
Shure:  现在都告原创了
Shure: Now everyone claims originality.
Jake: GPT直接写了啊还还
Jake: GPT writes it directly, and still...
Alice: 他们去哪了
Alice: Where did they go?